Hello,
welcome, welcome!
I just woke up from a dip.
I just woke up from a dip when I'm sleeping.
was supposed to play control today.
I was supposed to start control.
But, I was like, I really want to, I want to not, like, you
know, just be like, oh, I'm not feeling so hot, so maybe not
as much control today.
No.
I was like, I want to play it.
So, um, so because I have, I've been recording so much stuff
this week.
Mr. Sniffer, happy birthday!
I've been recording so much stuff this week that, um, my, I
woke up, or last night my throat was so, so sore.
Oh my gosh, I was struggling so much through the Peak collab
with the Sloppy Sisters.
I was like, I was like, oh my god, my throat hurts so bad.
My throat hurts so bad.
And so, um, uh, I woke up this morning and it was still
hurting.
So, today we are a little more chill.
We're just doing some crime scene cleaner because I enjoyed
that.
Oh, rise up, Dad Mark.
Thank you so much for that.
Oh, that guy's so fun.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
My birthday was on the 19th.
The stream of your concert was the present I bought for
myself.
I enjoyed it very much.
I think it was a little abrupt.
Abrupt?
Hmm?
How?
I don't know.
I don't know how the, how the, what's it called was the
stream, but thank you.
Thank you so much.
Happy birthday.
Mito sounds especially cute today.
I'm glad you think so because my throat hurts so much still.
I have my throat tea right here, so.
But since I...
Can't lie, I took a nap too?
Failed the nap, gotcha.
Oh, no!
Call of them!
Um.
What was I going to say?
Oh, I was gone for like a week, you know?
So I wanted to make sure I streamed.
i think some stream viewers missed the last mc after we did
the encore chant oh because that wasn't supposed to happen i
i have expressed multiple times to steiner i was like we
really need to start putting including like an encore in
these shows because people always do ask for encores but the
uh union was they were like get the heck out like after show
like they were pushing us literally like out of the out of
backstage they were like go like get out of here wish i
could watch but i have to go pick up my friend have fun be
safe
hmm so yeah
but um because usually like you know shows have like an
encore already planned but people just start chanting and i
was i was also i'm not frustrated but i was like hey um you
know you should probably like you know turn the lights on
and like you know stop showing the stage and everything
because people are gonna think there's an encore like you
gotta you gotta make it look
so yeah it was very it was it was a little haphazard but um
i was like i was like yeah can we like make it not look like
there's encore because sorry we're we do not have one
unfortunately we couldn't even do one even if we wanted to
because of the union and everything so
baby thank you jumble thank you stiner don't even say that
you've been streaming a lot look after yourself me though
yeah i mean it's only because i was gone i wanted to stream
i usually when i'm gone for like a week i'll like stream for
a full week to kind of do a little bit of ketchup but yeah
but yeah but yeah uh yeah but hopefully in the future maybe
well i it sounds awkward when i'm like hopefully the future
will have on course because they're not supposed to be like
a pre-planned They usually are a pre-planned thing.
They're not supposed...
It's a surprise pre-planned thing.
Just act like it's a surprise, you know?
Oh, Encore, yeah, Encore, yeah!
Woo!
Open secret, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hi, Minto.
Hello, Phil.
Awesome.
No way!
What?
Yeah, what?
Oh my god!
Oh, I can understand taking it easy after the peak stream.
Very cute merch, by the way.
Yeah, it's so cute.
We promised to be surprised.
Good, good, good.
I cast Throat Healing Beam.
Yeah, I have my...
I think I'll be...
I think I just overworked it this week, because I...
It has been non-stop.
Every day I've been recording something.
Yesterday was really rough, so I'm feeling extra tired
today, because I woke up and I recorded all day, collab and
then afterwards i had to record some more stuff so
yeah yeah so i'm i was like well yesterday was a lot a lot
of work but
yeah we can uh we can uh we'll just take it easy today and
uh just kind of rest up i don't know how long of a stream
it'll be i feel like you know with this game it's so easy to
like get into it and i i'm like oh yeah just one more room
one more room you know it's so fun so we all chilling yeah
we'd be chilling i hope you guys are having a good weekend
so far um the encore is kind of a ritual more than anything
yeah but i think it does make it a little awkward for us if
we're like oh we don't have anything you know i mean that's
not your you guys's fault but you know the the the there
should be like some sort of thing to be like thank you for
attending get home safe bye-bye rather than just kind of
keeping people hanging there and chanting when there's
nothing to go on and also not all shows have encore so
because sometimes it's just a time thing like they're quite
literal like you know I mean I it into the show, but yeah, I
don't know.
Sometimes it's tough.
Go home now.
Yeah.
Leave the building.
Exit the premises.
Get out of here.
No.
Sorry, I keep drinking my tea.
I'm sipping it while it's still hot.
But yeah.
They rolled credits on the screen and up the lights.
Yeah, probably.
But it's okay.
Like I said, we'll probably...
We...
Maybe we'll have an encore in the future!
Oh!
We're gonna try and build it into...
Build it into future sets.
But don't...
Don't...
You don't know that.
Trashbow, happy birthday!
Congratulations on the merch album, it's adorable!
Thank you, thank you!
Happy, happy birthday!
We have so many birthdays today!
birthday yeah it's a secret it's a secret i need advice
should i get persian food for dinner or dino nuggets and
maple syrup what a combo what a combo um dino nuggy i never
had it with a syrup though is it kind of like supposed to be
like chicken waffles because they have the waffles on the
you know that's what i liked about the densetsu's first 3d
live because there was a small logo at the end it was clear
when it finished yeah yeah yeah i think that should be um
standard right
oh sweet and savory yeah it's it is like chicken tenders and
waffles but without the waffles yeah Right, exactly.
The waffles were out of budget.
Oh, no.
No, chicken nuggy sounds kind of good.
Can you parallel park asking for a friend?
Are you asking for Ashton because...
Also, no, I can't parallel park.
I've failed that part of the driving test.
but i saw i saw some people under there under some vtubers
under there saying that they could parallel park so she's
gonna have to find another special talent i wonder what my
special talent is uh like so for context anybody wondering
what the heck um ashton martin uh fellow vtuber fellow
VTuber of Setsuna Setsuna productions was like she made a
tweet being like I want to find something that most VTubers
can't do or that I'm the only VTuber that can do it and I'm
like she was just like I can parallel park can any other
VTubers parallel park and I can't.
So she's got that on me.
The hand wave trick.
I wonder if anybody else can do the hand wave trick.
I wonder.
I think you have the best crash outs in the biz, boss.
I don't know.
I think other people can crash out, though.
Other people can crash out.
Yeah.
I mean, given how many VTubers there are, And how similar
humans and creatures are.
I mean, I was once a human.
So it's close enough.
I feel...
I would be really tough.
Ashton did explain the exit stage now thing was just a
misrouted stage direction.
Audium was not the venue telling you to get out, though.
Oh, but we were getting told to get out.
We 100% were getting told to...
I was there!
Don't tell me what the what it was happening They were like
they were they were like Phoebe was trying to pack up and
they were like can you do that in your room In your dressing
room they were 100% telling us to get out
But that was that was I wasn't even referring to that though
I forgot that happened actually I forgot that happened.
Hmm.
I don't know.
But, yeah.
Minto has the cutest, most infectious giggle.
And we go.
Nah, there's definitely others.
There's definitely others.
That's the other side of those anime people were so
well-behaved.
I heard that that was said too.
That they said that.
Everybody was like the, um, that, uh...
like you guys the the audience was they were like so they
were they were praising you guys and saying that you guys
were so well behaved and stuff so that's that's very good
that's always that's always better than the wiggles all
those dang kids out there
the speed oh my gosh sorry i have to i can't read super
chats very easily today um the speed they were breaking down
the stage when they rerouted the vip goodies line through
the theater after was crazy oh yeah we were watching it too
i was like oh my gosh they they were like i mean they
probably have that down to a science you know like it's just
second nature to them they're breaking down shows every day
so yeah shall we shall we get with the game and we keep
talking keep chit-chatting while we while we clean up some
suspicious scenes let's see where do we where where where
where we going short circuit oh that's right he made the
family think that they that the for anybody that doesn't
know i meant the audience wasn't supposed to hear it i know
the union was coming after you because they were shouting at
us to get out too no not at you guys They can shout at us,
but I don't want them to shout at you guys.
That's so mean.
But it's just how, sometimes that's just how stage places
and venues are.
But I'm sorry you got yelled at too.
I want you guys to not feel like you were...
I mean, obviously they need you guys to get out.
But I don't want you guys to be like, oh, that was such a
great show.
And then get yelled at and ruin the...
I mean, hopefully it doesn't ruin the vibes, but you know.
um uh this game has a bit of a story kind of basically we
are a we're a guy and we have a sick daughter and we have we
have taken up the job of crime scene cleaner to help pay for
her medical bills um so there's a bit of a story but it's
very like kind of underlying it's not super duper important
um but we accept these jobs and what was that I don't know,
something moves.
And so, yeah, we have a dog named Dexter, and he's very
cute.
But, yeah, we accept these jobs.
They tell us kind of what it's about, and then we go do
them.
So this time, some guy was, like, trolling this family.
And hacked their smart home system, and had them think the
house was haunted.
And then I guess there was a murder-suicide, because I
guess...
or something so let's go find out who went crazy what
happened hi dexter remember dexter bones i collect are not
snacks they're evidence evidence who are we who are we
holding that against very interesting this one is good i'm
excited i'm really enjoying this game it's like exactly the
but it'll be a long night the nice like lore drops are fun
too don't ask me why smart houses began to creep the shit
out of me i saw so many weird things all in one place no
wonder those people went mad if i didn't know i would have
gone mad too oh the rate cap you gave makes it sound like a
This one's scary One's neighbors to death The only way to
fight these insane housing Prices This one's scary Oh This
one's scary Oh my goodness Uh let's see Uh my lamp We'll
just uh Oh no they have a Okay, we can't open that.
What's this?
Such a little device.
So much carnage.
Oh my god, they have a...
How did you not notice this thing?
That was making scary noises behind your chair.
Oh?
Oh, I thought I heard, like, the cat.
Oh.
These places always have...
Wee!
I didn't do that.
Maybe I did, actually.
I'm not sure.
These places always have, like, candles that are lit.
It makes me worried.
A bit of a fire hazard.
Oops.
I shouldn't be touching that ball.
It's a... Yeah.
Ooh.
This looks pretty bad.
I mean, it is a murder-suicide.
Oh, no.
This is pretty bad.
I think there's more.
Oh, my God.
My spidey sense is cute.
Oh, not the cross.
Wait!
This job will kill me one day.
Why did that break?
I wish I could Turn on the...
Lights.
What's this?
Oh.
Yoink.
Sleep soundly.
Oh, F.
That's right, I bought a flashlight, you're right.
You're trying to access a protected folder authentication
required.
What's the brute force hacking?
that we got this is like me counting down yesterday yeah
suddenly the game is phasmophobia for this is this is the
house pre phasmophobia it was the cat that committed the
murder I was about to my first instinct was to be like no
but then maybe cough drops for me though Rikola!
Thank you!
If I click return, if I click exit...
It says sleep.
Oh, kitty!
Oh, God.
Oh, yeah, oh, I have a flashlight, that's right.
Let me out, let me out, let me out, let me out, let me out,
let me out.
That's my, that's the cat.
Let's just turn that off.
Holy water!
They're idle?
They're idle fan?
What did you do?
I can't turn that off.
I think I do hear a cat though.
Whoopsie.
Oh.
I thought I heard a cat going like, meow, meow.
The dinosaurs.
Mom is losing it.
What I see is small malfunction or some kind of glitch for
her is hard evidence as us being cursed or even possessed.
Her meds either don't work or she isn't even taking these
freaking pills.
Oh, it's funny because the text that's written on this and
then the text that is here is different.
Her meds either don't work or she isn't even taking them.
I hear a cat for sure.
Yeah, you hear it, right?
You hear it, right?
There's definitely a cat somewhere.
I don't know where to get help.
We're doomed.
May God have mercy on this family.
No.
God didn't help them.
It's not really his thing.
Oh, what the heck?
Who's putting the mannequin head in the...
I want to help the cat for sure.
Okay, we got...
Heated the living room.
Let's not do that.
Thank you.
Wait, what does that say?
Tuna is good fish.
I hate my neighbors.
The constant cacophony of stupidity that pours from their
apartment is absolutely soul-crushing.
It doesn't matter how politely I ask them to practice some
common courtesy.
They're incapable of comprehending that their actions affect
other people.
Comic sans.
I want to help the chaos.
Wait, was this lit up before or am I crazy?
Wait.
Oh, the light was not red before, was it?
That's a little freaky, huh?
Stop messing with this house.
And me.
I'm scared.
I guess let's get started on the first floor.
No, I definitely want to help the cat.
Not the room, but...
That haunted robot vacuum won't stop.
until I beat the shit out of it.
Oh my god!
Kitty?
They have pictures of their cat.
Watch the video with the cat.
Oh my god, they love their cat.
Oh my god, the purring is so nice, isn't it?
It's relaxing me.
Where's the kitty?
what why do i oh do you think this means oh because of the
collar oh no maybe there is no kitty no steals their steals
their cat stuff
well um we have the best television uh I can't tell.
It sounds like he's right here.
It's kind of weird.
They summoned the cat back.
Yeah.
Hey!
Ah!
I didn't... I didn't... I didn't... I don't know how that...
I didn't...
Kitty!
Hey!
Oh, that's why I heard it so clearly.
Ha ha ha ha.
That's... Okay.
To be fair!
I think...
Look at all this extra mess I have to clean up now.
This is so...
This is so typical of a cat.
I don't think...
I'm sorry.
I was a hacker hacking a smart... smart house.
How are they gonna...
How are they gonna do all this?
I'd rather not think you're for the 10 gifted.
How would they do that?
there there's no way oh uh let's see let's start mopping it
up now everybody uh we will put our bucket right here for
now very nice anything in here oh yoink cat's haunted that's
the only explanation hasn't it?
Are you clean?
Are you clean yet?
All we can do is start at one room at a time.
One room at a time, everybody.
Luckily, this one doesn't have so much.
But I'm kind of confused.
Because...
Okay.
Like...
Oh, there is a body!
I'm stepping on grandma.
I was going to say, who walked over here?
I guess she did herself.
Dang.
What baby...
Oh, sorry.
What baby is crying?
Stop it.
The devil's work.
Pack the matrix.
Truly.
The Roomba going is so funny, though.
Alright.
Oh.
Stealable items.
Yoink.
I think I saw it.
Yep.
Yoink.
And yoink.
Nice.
Can we listen to Holy Woda?
Sure.
Uh, wait, how do- what was it?
M?
Music.
I go.
Fire.
I'm not sure if it's my jam.
It's a little creepy.
Oh, he says Holy Water.
Holy Water.
So who is this?
A guy?
Surprise, there's not something scary sounding.
in here.
But then who is this?
Who are you?
Oh, oh my god.
She did that thing that guys do.
Where they're like, hey, you want to think I can jump and
touch the...
You know, why do guys do that?
Where they just jump and like touch the ceilings and stuff.
You know what I'm like, you gotta!
Well, some people have never been able to.
So I don't know.
You gotta slap the sign.
because it's fun sometimes my favorite thing is when you
like use for murder how it's so blunt um oh whoops uh like
it's so funny walking past a sign and there's just like it's
like super dusty except the bottom of it and it's just full
of like fingerprints from people jumping and touching it
just do it and you'll understand I'm telling you I'm telling
you I I can't maybe if I flow but that's like not as fine
right it's got to be a genuine jump and jump and hit right
gosh getting the foot getting the upgrade where my feet
don't track blood is like a godsend can you jump to your
door frames
maybe i'm too out of shape for that well jumping is a great
exercise like not even kidding it's a great form of exercise
so you just gotta get started you just gotta start and then
You can do it all the time.
Good for your health.
Well, exercise should be good for your health.
Oh, I almost missed some.
Hmm.
Pogo stick?
Maybe moon shoes.
Why did you walk all the way over here?
Was it to put the spooky speakers in?
All right, one room at a time.
We'll take care of upstairs first, and then we'll do the
downstairs.
So we have three bodies.
Delete surveillance recordings.
That must be.
We'll give you a shoulder to jump from.
Thank you!
That must be what's on the computer.
Yoink.
There's so many cat toys.
Okay.
Classic cleaning method, top to bottom.
It's true.
Was that a bong?
No.
It was a morocco.
Family friendly game.
Family friendly crime scenes.
What's this?
Oh.
My mom is scaring the sheesh out of me, dude.
What?
Why?
Let her.
I wake up and she's standing over my bed praying.
Didn't know she was so religious.
She wasn't, but now she thinks the devil lives in our house.
I'm packing my things and moving out of this place.
God dang.
Religious fanatics.
Oops.
Sometimes your mom is one of them.
Sometimes your mom.
Oh wait, I forgot.
We have that new thing.
Uh.
Not the pressure wash.
Additional tools?
Oh, here.
Cleaning procedures started.
voice.
Whoa!
This is kind of freaky.
Is there something there for me to clean?
What?
Spare no- oh, my bad.
Good to see you.
We have anime girl!
Let's go.
Help me clean, help me clean.
I don't remember what this thing is called.
Hey, buddy.
Let me just give you a good old wipe down there.
All right.
Good old sponge bath.
Something up.
What'd you say?
She said something.
You.
Oh.
Me.
Be a part of our story.
Me?
We had part of our story.
We're 10 cents or that, ex?
Oh, yes.
Now I don't have to clean up everything.
Only one bottle.
This is quite truly, like, the serial killer.
Like, I'm listening to classical music.
Cleaning up the crime scene.
You know what?
I think I would come into this place, and I would be
suspicious.
because it looks too clean you know what I mean like what
I'd be like why are the I can't get up help me senpai oh
time for cleaning maybe
offensive accent but now we know we can't knock it over I'm
gonna use the detergent for the big big room by the way um
oh wow wow it's like already getting stuff down here i'm not
quite sure what it's doing this room i'm still not over this
to be honest do you think she was like a crazy cat lady or
something i feel bad marking up the paws they're too cute we
did a bloody pet cat paw print
It has quite a reach.
It does, right?
Kind of crazy.
This is a great photo, by the way.
I love when you can see their little teeth like that.
Oh, having a catch.
The best thing ever.
Okay, I wasn't supposed to start on this room.
I've got a hunch on who the family favorite was.
Yeah, for sure.
Here, let's get back.
Let's get back to business.
Oh, is it clean or?
Wait, I can't really tell.
Have I started looking for a new cat yet?
I have not yet.
I have not had the time.
Oh.
Take it.
Get up.
Let's make it cozy again.
Is that what she just said?
I don't know if this place will ever be cozy again, but...
You know.
We could try.
There will be an attempt.
It interrupted the count!
Yeah, I'm mopping the bedsheets.
Don't worry about it.
40...
I don't know exactly what it's doing.
But I appreciate its help.
I suppose.
I think it's helping.
I think so.
These things seem easier to clean up.
Everything's...
getting gone and like one hit.
Hey, hey, move.
There we go.
Oh, okay, okay.
We gotta put some stuff up.
Okay.
Who's gonna look up there?
They're gonna think it's mold.
They're not gonna think it's blood.
Man, this covers the placebo effect.
No, no, no.
It's helping.
It's helping, right?
I'm still dealing with that.
They're still dealing with it.
And so it's my birthday!
Celebrate my supporting my hushie.
Rassamdull, thank you!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Appreciate it so, so much.
But you should also...
My janitor training comes in handy once again.
You should also get delicious stuff for yourself as well.
And support yourself.
and have a good time.
Is that everything in there?
Oh, I see the hamper.
Oh, whoops, cute.
Oh, steel?
A chair.
Oh, this one.
They would not care.
Sorry, someone coming in here would not care that the chair
is knocked over.
Oh, is that trash?
Getting some yummy lasagna.
Yummy lasagna!
Let's go!
Yeah, I know.
Say less I will get delicious stuff even though it isn't my
birthday.
I agree, you should, you should, you should.
Alright, this room seems clean.
So we're gonna...
Blood Force Trauma.
Hidden ahead many, many times.
Many, many times.
Oh, spooky.
Everything is clean?
Wait, how?
What did you do?
Oh, yeah, that's what I'm wondering.
Oh, how'd you do that?
What are you doing?
I'm starting to clean up.
Okay.
Shrink wrapping the body.
I want to see, like, does it disappear?
Watching paint dry.
She just makes it easier to scrub.
Okay, that's what I thought it was.
Yep, yep, you're doing a great job.
You're doing an amazing...
Oh, that looks like evidence.
Or a garbage?
That looks like a garbage.
Oh, there's a couple.
Okay.
So you got shot, like bad, bad.
Everybody be touching the...
The light switches.
All right, can we fix this now?
First things first.
Gotta scrub, scrub, scrub.
Oh, there's still some, yeah.
Okay, just kidding.
Gotta scrub, scrub, scrub.
There we go.
Weren't those shotgun shells?
I'm still getting going to that.
I think we found the shotgun.
And now I can use it.
Oh, I forgot about this room.
Oh, there's spooky sounds coming in here, too.
Oh, we'll come back.
This must be the grandma or mom's room or whatever.
What is this?
These anti-psychotics didn't work at all.
Ah, no.
Yikes.
Well?
Okay.
I hear something.
Oh, there it is.
How do you not notice this?
I'm sorry, there's speakers all over your house.
How did you not notice this one in plain sight that's
playing the creepy music?
Oh, we found them.
No, I want to see!
My morbid curiosity.
Alright.
Grandma forgot her glasses.
There's other people living here too though, no?
Where did those come from?
What?
The cat's making more of a mess for me.
Ghost cat.
Aw, poor ghost kid is like, probably like sad.
About mom.
This song's about.
I'm not a garbage man.
I'm a trash collector.
All right, we got, wait.
Maybe for upstairs we got all the stuff.
And there was one here.
Wait.
Let's just clean this up right quick.
This is the best song in the game.
It's really catchy.
Ta-ta!
Thank you.
No life is beautiful.
You're so right.
Nothing can beat life is beautiful, though.
Ah!
Toot, toot, toot, toot, toot, toot, toot, toot, toot, toot,
toot, toot, toot, toot.
Chew, chew, chew, chew, chew, chew, chew, my bad.
Chew, chew, hopefully.
Life is beautiful as imprinted on my brain.
Wasn't this song a better call Saul as well?
It better not have been, because otherwise I'm going to
get...
I think these are original to the game.
Or I hope so at least, because otherwise...
My channel's getting yoinked.
It's a tiny gift, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you.
I know I shouldn't be mopping the...
Actually, we can, uh...
What is it, three?
Three?
Yeah.
Did I get the...
Did I get the update or the upgrade that allows me to hold
two mops?
I can't remember.
I miss you.
You miss me?
I'm right here!
Why would you miss me?
Oh, nice.
Lots of stealables.
Steel.
Oh.
Did I grab this?
Grandpa Garampas.
Wait.
That wasn't there before.
We literally...
The getaway murder.
Wait, we literally grabbed the tape that was here before.
This place might actually be haunted, right?
You play it?
I'm scared.
Folk.
Okay, I'm right here.
It's got...
Oh my gosh, really?
It's a little creepy.
Holy Woda was in the room with the laptop.
Was it?
Cleaners and Ibu confirmed.
It's like chill and creepy at the same time.
Like, there's like creepy...
There's like creepy vocals in it.
Lo-Fi.
Spooky lo-Fi.
It's a little...
Little creepy.
A little bizarre.
Oops.
Don't...
Time for cleaning complete.
Yeah, slightly unsettling.
Just a little unsettling, yeah.
It looks fine now.
Holy moly.
Alright.
Oh my gosh.
I think I'm going to change the voice.
I don't know if this is any better.
Might be worse.
actually oh my bed might be worse hey hey uh my name is decu
and my wish is to be the best hero ever but i was born
without a quirk
god no oh oh Oh, he's talking.
He's talking.
What'd you say?
I want him to say something.
Speak.
I need cash in here.
Cat, more cat toys.
So funny.
Oh, yeah.
Nice.
What's that?
Yoink.
More.
I can't help you while I'm lying down.
Okay.
you what refreshing the air air purification complete okay
that's not as bad as i thought it was gonna be it's
splattered in all directions yeah the blood in this oh oh
yippee oh the first floor has been clean wait there's
nothing in here oh i forgot that there was a water
whatever this is not even like a like a garage or something
that has like access to the outdoors this is their second
floor why is this room like this it's like a garage type
area but it's just up here it's kind of strange we'll just
leave that alone um all right buddy you come with me oh what
why'd you say that why'd you why'd you say that why'd you go
oh why'd you do that I don't like it initializing process of
purification hello there I like him hello there okay we'll
do this for the kitty paws probably a renovated room
probably a former storage room or main maintenance room must
be something like that right oh oops my bad i did not right
open must have been a heavy caliber painted the walls red
yeah pretty brutal i didn't mean to punch you man
all right let's clean up the kitty room
i'm sorry little kitty i'm sorry Yeah, I...
I haven't started looking for a cat yet.
I'm not particularly picky.
Like, I'm not gonna be looking for any certain kind of cat
or anything, you know?
Like, I'm just kind of...
Anybody that I think vibes with me is good.
I know some people, like, kind of go for certain, like,
breeds and stuff.
I think, though...
Spare no one.
no one's so funny i feel like breeds really matter for dogs
but for cats i mean there are certain like differences but
it's not nearly as big of a deal hoping your next cat
doesn't have ibs even if they did that would be okay i'd
still love them love love your cat or your partner even if
they have ibs it's not their fault
Though I want a main coon Norwegian forest or just a big
chunky cat.
Understandable.
Main coons are so cute and they're so sweet.
Like, if I could find a rag doll, I would because they're so
sweet, you know?
It's time for a perch.
They're very, very sweet.
Because dispose of garbage bags.
Rich request, can we have a Minto voiced air purifier?
I have thought it would be fun to do like, what's it called?
I thought I had seen more more cap, more paw prints.
GPS or something, you know.
Behold my power.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They loved this photo enough.
They have it twice.
And I'm not...
I'm not quite sure why.
Turn left.
Now!
Nice.
Oh, our thing is dirty though.
I'm gonna bring... Oops.
Oh gosh.
Oh, my bad.
I'm so sorry.
I'm going to bring our bucket in here.
Minto nasally virtual GPS DLC.
Okay, good thing I emptied.
Easy.
Put you right...
Here.
We can't...
We can't knock this guy over, so...
Okay.
I don't think he's...
I don't see anything else to...
steal.
I'm gonna...
Let's do some garbage bags.
I take you as my...
piece of trash.
There's so much here.
no fear i like him
they ordered one photo and then bought one at the convention
because they forgot that they ordered what already why does
this sound this sounds very like a bunch of personal
experience dorgal i mean that was not my birthday but i just
found out i passed my bachelor's exams now halfway to being
a doctor oh bantam congratulations that's huge You studied,
you did so well, you worked so hard!
Congratulations!
What's this now?
Everything started when Adam got back home from Michigan.
Changement day is coming, soon.
The first thing I noticed was the sudden temperature
changes.
It was either so cold in here...
that you could see your breath or so hard that it felt like
a fever then things started moving on their own that night
at that point I was sure Adam was possessed okay I'm sorry
they said she was like 45 my little boy save his soul from
the evil spirit within him why is she sound 70 fear and
delusions let her murder whoa evil laughs Evil voice.
How old does the dev think 45 is?
Yeah, she sounds like 39.
You're so right.
Careful.
Oh, grandma.
Who's not really a grandma?
Does she have something in her hand?
or am I crazy?
Give me a new enemy.
A new enemy.
What was I doing?
Oh, collecting garbage still.
I wanted to get all the garbage off the floor.
I think we got it.
Awesome.
Looks like a ring.
I feel like it's maybe the dagger that she stabbed herself
with.
Which is really hardcore.
Like, okay, grandma has metal no jump scares let's keep it
that way why did you say that why did you say it like that i
i also wish for no jump scares not that kind of game no
why why am i expecting one now i'm scared judgment day is
coming soon judgment day is coming soon all right
Hello, my goodness.
I gotta look up because I gotta clean the stinking ceiling.
There is a lamp on the upstairs hallway that you should take
a look at.
Is there?
Ryoka.
Thank you for the super chat and for the suggestion.
Upstairs hallway.
Alright, give me one second.
Lamp on the upstairs hallway?
That?
Wait.
There are no lamps, or?
Oops.
The wall lamps.
Is it going to be a jump scare for real?
I'm scared.
I'm pressing interact on all of them.
Hmm.
punch I wonder if there's like anything under here no
did you see it oh wait it's crooked wait but it won't let me
fix it can I punch it punch it into the straightening a
little lick pressure wash it you
got to get stupid clothes really I think I saw open you
can't have haunted house without secret room touch the lamp
and see what happens
whoa secret discovered thank you I definitely wouldn't have
seen this holy 700 Did
you guys hear that?
The piano.
Piano BGM goes kind of hard though.
I'm scared to turn around!
Kitty!
Oh my god.
Oh, the face is gone.
This stinking cat!
You!
Oh, cat!
I already cleaned.
I already finished.
I finished this area.
I was half expected to see grandma standing by me.
I was ready to see her.
Right there.
At least we got the fun music.
Sorry, mister.
The cat took care of me.
your face can't open these drawers oh nothing else right all
right yeah uh cool nice thank you for telling me about the
uh about the secret you
were bracing for dear life Dear Afterlife, too.
Give me a new enemy.
You go.
Oh, I think over here.
Okay, we'll wait.
Alright.
Very good.
Fight the Roomba.
Oh.
It will...
It won't let me do anything except punch it.
There we go.
You go right here.
The room was very strong.
You go nowhere.
Are you dirty?
I wish I could rotate it.
No, it's not dirty.
Oh, there it goes.
Okay, never mind.
Oh, 30.
Imagine you buy, like, a used couch.
You're like, totally...
Oh, dang it.
I did not mean...
Totally fine, new used couch.
And you look behind the one cushion.
Don't look behind your cushions.
It's totally fine.
There's definitely not blood behind there.
Just a happy little new used couch.
Exactly, exactly.
Hang it.
Come on.
There we go.
Let's not be...
Let's not be stubborn.
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Very good.
This place is gonna look brand spank and new.
No one's ever cleaned it before.
Yuki Pro Cleaner versus Rumba Boss fight.
I think my Yuki Pro Cleaner would wipe.
I know no fear.
The Roomba.
My guy literally says I know no fear and is And is kind of
scaring me sometimes
Oh, oh, oh Do I have to clean them?
Imagine him as Doom guy He's doing it all for his bunny Does
this work?
Ah The judgment day is coming Ah So she must have trashed a
place herself.
Why'd she do that?
Why?
Why'd you trash the place?
To give me more work to do?
Not very funny.
Hey, I quit it.
Quit it, man.
You're not doing anything.
You're not helping me at all.
Poor Daisy.
Daisy.
Aruba's got to go.
It won't even let me pick it up.
Where did these go?
Maybe on this, like these...
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I see.
Um, are you good?
Are we good?
You're rolling?
Oh, fingerprints?
Uh, you go...
Oh my god, don't fall!
Don't fall!
You go right here.
You go right there.
And the other cushion...
Clean?
Spick and span goes there.
Ran whating new?
What?
Hecking new.
Your objective is to destroy it!
I'm wearing my silly Densitou headband.
I silly now.
You didn't even need to wear it to be silly.
I'm gonna punch it.
Wow.
Strong.
Wait, where the heck is this supposed to be?
It's a go actually.
That doesn't give me a location.
At least it didn't seem like it did.
Oh, this needs to be...
I know no fear.
I should bring...
Breakables can go anywhere as it assumes you'll break stuff
by accident.
Which I've done maybe once or twice.
But don't make a habit of it.
I see a handprint on the vase.
Oh really?
Still?
I thought I got it.
Nah, it's clean.
It's clean.
Look at that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's clean.
Clean.
What is that?
In LA, this could have been a whole apartment.
Yoink.
Harry Potter and the Goblet of Clay.
Yeah, this is exactly the read I was hoping for right now.
Autobiography of a Potter.
Harry loves bowling.
A master potter.
Recounts his remarkable journey from humble beginnings to
acclaimed artisan in this autobiography.
He's a potter and he likes bowling.
Harry's early years were shadowed by tragedy as he lost his
parents to one of the world's most infamous serial killers,
Volt Day Mord.
Cast into the confines of a cramped room beneath his
cousin's stairs, Harry's life took an unexpected turn when
he unearthed his innate talent for pottery.
Fueled by an unwavering determination to pursue his passion,
he immersed himself in the art, dedicating countless hours
to his studies at the pottery school.
Yet just as success appeared within his grasp catastrophe
struck all of harry's painstakingly crafted works were
ravaged his vases shattered and his dreams left in ruins
despite the crushing blow harry refused to surrender to
despair instead he summoned the inner strength to persevere
rising from the ashes as he shattered as he as his rising
from the ashes of his shattered ambitions there's pottery
school there's gotta be there's school for everything
undeterred by setbacks harry embarked on a journey of
unwavered in his pursuit of mastery and amidst the trials
and tribulations he achieved a triumphant milestone the
completion of fuck this motherfucker who destroyed my
workshop and all the vases I will find you and I'll kill you
HL bowling only water
in there weird and a big thing of cheese she hungry grandma
all right sounds like a good read honestly yeah it sounds
pretty good i need to read did the did the guy get caught it
doesn't sound like it i guess harry became a huge fan of
security cameras after that i imagine cheese to meet you
she's not cheese to meet anyone anymore grandma you oh Oh,
you!
Stop it!
Oh my god.
Wait, wait!
Stop!
You either die cleaning or live long enough to be cleaned.
We killed the Roomba.
We destroyed the evil.
Oh.
He was making... Look at all of this!
I bet that there wasn't even a, like, a pentagram here.
He did it himself.
He probably programmed the thing to go around in a star
shape.
Gosh, there's so much blood here.
Room was trying to conceal the evidence.
I don't think he's concealing anything.
In fact, he wants it all to be really, really obvious.
He's like, check out the blood.
It's quite literally everywhere.
And here I go, like, smearing it all over the floors even
more.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
We've got just a little bit on, like, this side of the room.
Oh, we gotta get rid of this?
Yeah, get bagged, bozo.
get rid of the trash we have one more furniture to move back
one more furniture to move back
exercise the rumba the house is clear the cat in the rumba
we're in cahoots truly do not disturb the ritual rumba get
disturbed get disturbed yeah i do have the body but i mean
what could be the for a piece of furniture i don't think the
oh oops i don't think i think this body is holding something
oh sorry grandma oh wait interact after she killed her
family she finally stabbed herself in the heart That's where
maternal love comes from.
Oh, gosh.
Why did she do that?
She, like, posed afterwards.
Wait, it isn't dead.
Rumba surprise.
There's a good day your head and death in its eyes.
But you can do jujitsu.
Actual.
Uh.
Oh, oops.
My bad.
Actual Rumba.
Shia LaBeouf.
She, like, flexed.
on me real fast she was like check this out scare me all
right we wiped all the blood okay oh i guess oh yeah i
forgot there was that evidence now what furniture needs to
be moved back
i think it's the last chair on the weirdly big place dining
table oh freak you
Oh, wait, where is that?
How'd that fall over?
Oh, here it is.
That's funny.
Yay!
We did it!
See you kitty kitty!
Oh my goodness, you're so cute.
Oh, you're so cute.
Oh my god, oh my god, what's this?
Uh, time to go?
Yes.
Yay!
Yay, yay, yay!
I think we could do one more one.
Delveray!
I haven't had a chance to properly tune in until now.
It was fantastic meeting you and then to die AMYC last week.
Thanks!
We ran out of time back then, but the other thing I wanted
to recommend was other Platinum games.
Uh, since you liked Metal Gear Rising, Beyo, that'll be 101.
Wait, what's W101?
Actually, it's funny because I was like, when I was making
my schedule for this week, I almost added Bayonetta.
But I was like, I should probably start control though, so I
can play Alan Wake 2 for Halloween.
Wonderful 101.
Thank you guys.
I wonder what you do the money for.
I guess it's just to help our...
I thought it would be for buying like new equipment, but I
think it's just for Nice, we got both.
Thanks to you guys' help.
What was I saying?
I was probably just going towards our medical bills.
Dexter, why are you looking in the corner again?
What's up, Dexter?
Let me guess.
Your tail?
Why?
He keeps looking in this corner and it's freaking me out.
Stop!
There's no cats in it.
No, stop it.
I'm scared.
Stop looking at the corridor.
Dexter, you're scaring me.
Hey, those are those are funny plugs.
Oh my god, our place is haunted.
It's so...
Who is that?
I think the ghost cat is... Wait a second.
That wasn't there before.
Oh, I think we get a new... Did we steal a photo?
I think we get a new thing with every house we clean.
Or every location we clean.
I think we stole a photo of the cat.
I think the cat is now haunting us?
Oh, heck yeah.
Nice.
Go to bed.
Oh, there was something over there.
Maybe I missed it.
Yeah, you got a weed plant from the dealer's house.
Oh, Matteo's pizzeria!
Jim, we've let him do whatever he wants for far too long.
Fuck yeah, it's time we teach this motherfucker who
really...
Did someone call for Big Jim?
Sometimes this game is so quiet, and other times it's...
Oh my...
That might be our first time seeing, like, a character
model.
This should the day is Big Jim's head.
Who's laughing now?
Very good.
It's just pasta sauce.
Of course, marinara, everyone.
Please, please.
I swear, I won't tell it.
Too much docking.
Oh.
Oh yeah, baby.
Ready for a slice.
Come on, let me have just one.
or the whole thing delicious where's my phone go this is Jim
what she did at Mike's was good night yeah they have to take
care of some backstabbing fuckers scheming against me at
Mateo's pizza a whole pizza yeah why not so we bear some
body bags Kovowski a whole lot of them how many So now I'm
eating their last pizza.
Wait, really?
What if it was?
And I just ate the whole thing in one go.
Wait, Mateo's pizza is no more.
I ate the whole thing.
Oh, man.
I'm never going to be able to get it again.
I wasted it.
Are you hungry, Dexter?
Do you like pizza?
Do you like a pizza?
Oh, he loves pizza.
There was something here and I missed it.
Oh no.
Wait, though.
Look at this.
We're, like, cleaning the place up, actually.
Like, we're painting and stuff.
Huh.
You murdered the pizza, too.
I'll do it again.
Exist to be happy, not to impress.
That's new.
This is new.
Sure hope that was marinara.
Or 1.24.58 canoli.
up the house is changing other hi dad it's been tough it's
been a tough day and i just need to get this out i made some
friends but some kids are stupid i told katie that my dad
works as a janitor and then the whole table started laughing
at me it was so mean everyone was mocking me i was so done
with it that i just had to leave but don't worry dad i know
you work really hard and i'm glad to be your daughter please
give dexter a nice treat from me love you Aww.
All right, we'll do the restaurant.
It says it's a little bit bigger than 11 bodies.
It says it's a little bigger than the other place, but.
You did great at Mike's Wellness Center, but that was just
the appetizer compared to the next task I have for you.
Take all the supplies you need and head to Mateo's pizza.
Expect a freaking bloodbath.
11 bodies.
Yeah, it's a massacre.
It's insane.
Yeah, it doesn't say like...
Well, I guess it does say dad's cave still down there.
And we've got a shelf and a bunch of soup.
It's great.
Things are going well.
We're improving the place.
Getting ready for our daughter to get better and come back
to us.
So Big Jim is the boss, pretty much.
He's like the big head honcho mob boss.
boss around here.
This is a big level, if I remember correctly.
That's okay.
Italian, Joel.
What a massacre.
Here I thought that I'd finally gotten used to this job.
I couldn't be proved any more wrong.
That made me realize that there's no escaping big Jim.
At least not if I didn't want to be full of holes like a
cheese.
Like a cheese!
Hmm.
Wait, this is different.
We don't usually, like, get out of the car like this.
Is something going to happen?
Oh!
We're in the back alleys.
No.
Dang, we drive a land shaker pro.
And we're also really small, I think.
We had a busy night, so expected to do with 11 parties.
Okay, understood.
Oh, and uh, one more thing.
Oh, hi.
Some old hag started yelling at us from the window, so he
stopped the mouth with some bullets.
Back there.
Sure thing.
Oh, my God.
Let's get the word.
Oh, my God!
Mama Mia!
This place looks more tangled than the pasta in my cabinara.
Baa, Baa Mia!
this is this is crazy this is crazy work
cold take you shouldn't be able to lock yourself inside an
industrial freezer oh my god everywhere i turned oh the
onions oh no why'd you put your hand on the dough oh by the
real mobsters that's the opposite of ironic oh okay i'm just
gonna tammy remember mr gotty and his friends are much more
important than our regular customers.
So speak only when spoken to and do not even come near their
table unless you're called.
Please, for the love of God, try not to fuck it up tonight!
Yeah, what a waste of pieces, Oz.
Oh my goodness.
So, what secrets do you hide?
Interesting, interesting, interesting!
Oh!
Yoink, yoink, yoink.
And...
They were playing solitaire.
Can I play?
No.
Very vampire.
No, it was...
Oh, my...
Oh.
What a mess.
What a mess, indeed.
Oh, come on, man.
Take that.
Oh, wow.
That's so embarrassing for him.
Oh, come on.
Punch!
What?
No?
Okay.
Let's keep looking around a little bit.
Nobody noticed this from outside?
What?
It can't...
I mean, even at like 2 in the morning, there's always
people.
This mission is what got me to buy the axe perk.
Oh, I forgot.
got to buy perks that's right i got some more let's say my
mom i love my mom family bingo collecting debts to sarah
something t of a mo a mo mr goti scolds us someone calls
martino marty a light elio smuggles cheap prosco let's go
gambling talking I can't read it I give up
does this lead to the girl that we saw earlier uh
is this the girl that they meant was no they said someone
was yelling at us right yelp reveals for reviews for this
place not promising
from a window yeah you said from a window so we'll have to
figure out how to to get into there.
All right, let's start cleaning up the bodies.
Oh, sorry.
I did the wrong thing.
One bullet hit her leg.
The other went through her neck.
Poor girl.
This wasn't supposed to happen to her.
Yeah.
She's fine.
Another innocent soul ending up in a body bag in my car.
Am I the real monster now?
Am I the monster?
Because I'm already a demon.
Why aren't you answering your phone working right now?
Sorry, please find another job Mateo's pizza seems fishy
someone says mr.
Gotty owns it or owns the owner Please stay out of it not
every Italian-American is mobbed up at least be careful
Okay, me and mom will come see you in a day or two.
Can't wait.
Oh
All right, you Cleaning procedures started what do you want?
Uh...
What was I doing?
I don't remember.
Oh, I was gonna check the skill tree, actually.
Let's do!
Let's do... We have eight.
General.
Increased weakening speed.
I guess we could get the handy axe.
What's this?
Oh, reduces movement speed.
Penalty.
Can't buy on the job.
Wait, you can't?
Oh, no!
Extra bucket sounds huge, too.
Oh, no.
Where is the extra bucket?
Oh, the soap spray attachment, self-cleaning attachment.
You sound huge too.
Additional sponge.
I still smell blood here.
Mop and sponge can no longer leave blood stains.
But I'm pretty careful, I think.
Is it under tools, maybe?
Two buckets you can cheese the soap.
Where is the second bucket?
Water?
Oh, here.
Improved bucket.
You can pour two detergents into the bucket.
Additional bucket one and an additional bucket two.
Yeah, let's do that.
Increased bucket capacity.
Two.
Five.
I'm gonna do this.
Thank you, cutie!
Yeah, well, soon.
Oh, thank you!
I'm okay.
I just need a little extra time.
Um...
So now we'll have three buckets.
Maybe...
How many more?
Uh, yes.
Maybe I can get an extra mob.
Yeah.
Let's get an additional mob.
Increases the speed of using.
Ooh, we can get that next time.
Alright.
Cool.
So now I can hold two.
But where is the second one?
How do I get the second one?
under additional tools no
looks the same to me hmm I think it's so funny that like the
the uh footprints like walk to the crime scene but there are
none walking away where's the I am the victor I am the
victor
you'd have to quit and come back for the park to take.
It doesn't, oh, it doesn't do it on the job.
Oh no, that must be for everything then.
Oh no!
Oh no, I didn't realize.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, okay, wait, I realize, I recognize this place.
Did I not put a bucket down?
But now you have all set for next time it says so on the
menu well i can't read okay are you gonna make fun of me for
not being able to read that's insensitive i'm just kidding
by the way okay maybe we do leave and then come back or if i
restart or respawn i guess respawn
pretty sure it only says you can't switch not that you can't
buy i think it's silly that it allows you to buy during the
mission when it's not gonna apply you know what i mean
uh yeah i haven't done so much if i restart i guess let's
try
we didn't do that much i can just yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that made me realize
that there's no escaping big gem at least not if i didn't
want to be
No, it didn't let me grab another bucket.
Oh, I see.
Okay, I think I have to hold it.
Okay.
We got it.
Okay, understood.
Actually, I got a key for cold storage, but I'm not...
I'm not sure where...
That is.
Sure thing.
All right, let's get to work.
So what secrets do you hide?
All right.
That's the opposite of ironic.
Okay.
Did it say the axe?
I thought I picked it up, didn't I?
I didn't.
Wait, I could have sworn I did.
Wait.
Oh, did I not?
Oh my gosh.
No!
I could have sworn I did.
Yeah, because I thought I said click save or whatever.
Oh, I must have clicked the don't save.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, let me see.
Oh, okay.
I think I...
I actually commented on this before where I was just like,
why is the yes not here and the no not here?
Whoops.
You're supposed to click don't, don't save.
Yeah, you're right.
I think they're European.
I think so, too.
I don't know what gave it away, though.
Even though the game takes place in America?
I guess we will start again.
Sorry, guys.
Unless?
never mind we don't need to start again baby we don't need
to start again we're so good everything's fine okay i was
gonna say it was only i remember it being only some
some perks why is there cereal in that drawer that don't
apply while you're on the mission But I knew that some did.
And I'm guessing that the buckets did apply.
And the mobs did apply.
And I just wasn't clicking it correctly.
We're fucked, boss.
Big Jim knows all about the meeting and Mateos.
Knows all about the deal.
Run.
Answering this one would save many lives.
Ah.
Ripperoni.
Let's see.
I feel like starting in here would be pretty good because we
can uh just kind of take care of this room.
Oh.
Yeah, that needs to go back there.
Let's see.
Come on.
Be clean.
Yeah, there we go.
We can just start with this room.
Uh, I'm not gonna do that just here.
it okay all right oh actually yeah nice um is this evidence
oh my bad my bad so sorry so sorry for that so much ketchup
i know my goodness uh we'll put we'll put our favorite guy
in here too oh That's a pressure washer.
Just kidding.
We'll put our favorite guy right here.
Refreshing the air.
Bingo.
Yeah.
I think it's better to just kind of take it one room at a
time.
And so we shall.
Oh, I forgot to set up my bucket too, though.
Yeah, I do not know where the...
Another proof that more people should start reading.
The cold room is.
Dear Mr. Cook.
I know you have zero respect for anyone who is not God slash
Gordon Ramsay, but you should listen when I tell you to take
the God there.
damn key to the cold room.
Do you want to get stuck in there like that guy in the
shining?
Do you?
Oh.
Oh, it's right here.
Ah, ah, ah.
Ah!
So, they turned it into an interrogation room.
What kind of a chicken is that?
Oh, my bad.
Dun, dun.
You like?
Maybe I started here, though.
Just a little more effort in room will be ready.
Thank you.
It's a white chicken, a piggy.
Oh my bad.
I like a little cold, mister.
Oh he made it.
We were so close.
He's alive!
He's standing on his own!
I... Oh, hello?
Oh, come on, I don't know my own straight.
Come on, man!
The ragdolls...
The ragdoll physics in this game!
There we go.
Oh, that was like a perfect...
Oh.
How did this guy get all the way over?
I think he's alive too!
Don't be like that.
We'll come back.
Okay, grab you.
It's another chat time to think.
Are you finally in a mood to talk?
Shit, he dropped there already.
Why do I always fuck things up?
He really deserves a cold shoulder for a fuck-up like that.
Ooh.
Um, I guess this room is...
Oh, dang it.
Ah, get it, get it, get it.
How strong are you?
You're just throwing them all over.
I know, that's why I'm the best in the biz.
I can punch tables.
I can throw bodies.
I can't do it like no one else can.
Oh, what's this?
I think this room is good then.
I think this room, I think the cold room is good then.
me being like where's the cold room I pass by it like five
times
pulling nails or teeth or nipples
it's best to do it in the cold room because they're sticking
straight up you know all right we'll use our sponge for this
oh yeah I do have multiple mobs now so true multiple
sponges.
I'm ready for more work.
Okay, well, give me a second.
How am I supposed to know?
Well, that's fine.
Ah!
Oh, excuse me.
Oh, sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Excuse me.
All right.
Back to our one...
One room...
One room at a time.
Methodology.
Okay.
I think I'm gonna break everything.
Whop, pop, pop, pop.
Where'd it go?
I think it actually clipped out of the world.
I can remove up to 99% of harmful particles from the air.
Wait, it says it's supposed to be up there, but it's
actually missing.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Um.
Golden pizza.
Wait.
I don't think...
Did it, like, clip out here?
Surely it's fine, right?
Check the other room.
Oh yeah, let's check the...
Oh!
I found it!
What?
We're fine, everything's fine.
We don't need to restart.
We're all good.
Everything's good.
Everything's A-okay.
know how that happened or why.
But we made it work.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, my bad.
It just rolled away and did not stop rolling.
You... I like how we're supposed to put things away, but we
can still steel so like we actually end up like creating
strange is this open strange gaps in it that looks more
suspicious most terrifying thing in the game so far why was
it so strange I
can remove up to 99% the one pizza parlor built on
Skinwalker Ranch.
Holy cow!
Just another Minot supporter!
Thank you for being our sunshine.
Well, we all, we, we, wait, all we can see is darkness.
Love you from the bottom of our hearts.
From a Minot supporter.
What the heck?
Thank you!
I should clean it first.
So much.
I really appreciate it.
Don't be seeing darkness.
Oh, sorry.
Look at that.
Look at this.
I'm ready for more work.
Sir?
Much love, Vinto.
All I do is stream.
I'm glad you guys like it though.
I can't open it from this side.
That's right.
So thank you for supporting and watching and everything.
I really appreciate it.
I think our grandma might be over this way.
Wait, do I climb up this?
Wait, what is this?
Huh.
Secret?
Maybe.
Maybe there's a way I can get over there.
Like so.
Oh wait.
I found it all on my own, guys.
Are you proud of me?
Welcome to the Not So Underground concert.
Secret discovered!
What's here?
Oh!
Haunting vocals plunge you into a psychedelic whirlwind of
sonic madness.
Or just your daily life madness.
Your personality alone is enough to brighten our days.
Like I said, I'm just, I'm just, I'm just being a little,
little butt head every day.
Man, those robo-ow dudes are tripping.
First they go into the city and their bassist manages to go
missing.
Like seriously, where the heck does he even wander off to?
Then to top it off, they decide to redecorate the bar with
their puke.
Rock and roll's all about the wild ride.
But tonight's gig, yeah, it's a bust.
Robow?
It's nice to see Robo still.
Oh, Robo.
Thanks, little duckie.
Why does it sound like that?
Oh.
Oh, we're fine.
Oops.
This is cool.
Who is Robo?
I'm missing a something.
I'm missing a clue about it.
All right.
We already read that, unfortunately.
Um, let's, uh...
Yeah, let's bring this guy out here now.
Help me out, help me out.
We're gonna take the big room on last.
Uh, and I'm going to take her.
Oh, sorry.
I didn't mean to do that to you, Tammy.
Poor girl.
to happen to her.
So four bodies?
All right.
How do we get to the person in the window?
Maybe over here?
Oh.
Whoa.
Kitty.
Don't forget to water plants and yourself.
Punch.
Oh.
I got an achievement.
It says, what a beast.
I guess we're punching so many things.
Is there anything in here?
I got Ayami's Mint Book and my first comic kit!
That one, I hope you had so much fun!
I hope you had so much fun!
When I came back home, everything was already in ruins.
We took her?
Bastards demolished the entire state.
And then, then all I could save was that little plant.
This guy?
One only little plant.
The gardener's still...
Sounds weirdly familiar.
Yeah, right?
Oh, so this is...
This is trash now.
Dang it.
Hmm, still trying to find out how to get to the old lady
that yelled at them.
Oh, we got parkour up there.
Oh, no, no.
How often do you think is better?
Two weeks.
One month.
Of what?
Granny's apartment.
Oh.
I'm sorry.
This is way too much.
no context I boo am I gonna rob granny granny you better not
have any stacks of cash in your drawers oh no she has a
kitty too what about the kitty
granny oh my god don't talk to me or my sons ever again.
Am I the only one that has, like, never had a cat that likes
these?
I heard.
I heard something ringing.
I heard...
You hear it?
Mint, if I pass on, you have to pull my teeth or other
parts.
I just want to say, I understand.
Well, make it quick, please.
Oh, whoops.
That's not what I meant to do.
I'm not pulling.
in parts?
Why would we be pulling them?
You know.
When you're dead.
Oh, dang it.
My cat and I are watching this stream together.
Shield their eyes.
Grandma is dead and that's scary for the kitty.
Shield their eyes, please.
Come here, Grandma.
Alright, go over there, Grandma.
Go over there.
Dang, nice split.
She still got it.
She was probably a gymnast in her younger days.
I didn't mean anything weird, but it is a secret.
Ah, I see.
I see, I see.
What was the question?
Wait, hold on.
Okay, hold on.
How often do you think it's better?
Two weeks, one month.
I think...
One month.
The amount of blood everybody's leaving behind is almost
fisted the North Star level.
That's what I'm saying.
Like, it's just an egregious amount every time.
Everybody has hemophilia.
Truly.
oh dang it
i'd say one month do you have a favorite camera that you use
to take checkies um not really yeah i just use like a
regular um like in stacks mini is quite common um mine mine
i don't have it anymore but she she was all reliable she
lasted a really long time so what other blood is in here 89%
oh all of this too this is just pain this ain't blood is no
one gonna think it's suspicious that grandma's gone or okay
grandma's grandma's is clear
can't have anyone thinking grandma was messy
all Oh, Grandma.
Alright, come on.
Come on, Grandma.
Come on.
Alright.
We've got 5 out of 11 bodies now.
For real.
He's listening to us!
Kovansky, shut up!
Shut up, shut up!
There's nothing to do here.
Does- So if I get rid of him from this area, like, the blood
is already still easy to clean up than before.
Like, is that how that works?
Because, I mean, I could start having him start cleaning the
other room, you know?
I mean, let's do that, because we're already almost done
with this part, so.
E-Y-Y-Y-Y-Y-Y-Y-Y-Y-Y-Y.
Sorry.
I'm being a little.
I'm being a little, um...
Initialist.
There we go.
a little rough with him all right we did this room did this
oh wait no we're still here what have I yet to do ah oh
there we go I need to clear the way first it is no what's
missing something is blocking the way is it this
It really was the cup.
Wait, that's kind of crazy Okay There's this here that I've
been curious about attention losers that goddamn elevator in
the hotel is busted again again Now we've got to haul our
asses down this freaking long ladder if any of you idiots
don't remember this yet keys to the hatch are in the kitchen
I wonder what kind of secret ingredients do they keep in the
basement?
He's to the hatch.
Oh, no.
What is it down here?
Surely they didn't go down here, though, because it's
covered up, right?
Jesus.
Is that some ladder to hell?
We're fine.
That's where they were making the real dough.
Oh.
And I will also be making the real dough, and I will be
taking it home with me.
Yeah, baby.
Take every single one to Vegas.
Are you out of your mind trying to play Russian roulette
with a mecherov?
It's not Russian.
It's an Italian roulette.
That's not the point.
If your such is softy, then I'll start.
Good thing someone has already cleaned up after this idiot.
Oh, what's up?
Happy belated birthday!
I played Peace Walker with my friend for the first time and
it was a blast.
It made me really wish MGSV had multiplayer too.
I crave more MGS co-op now.
Yeah, it's so fun, isn't it?
Oh, happy birthday.
I'm glad you had fun with it.
Can't toss bodies like they weigh nothing but moving a mini
cabinet plus a mug?
Yeah, too much to ask.
i'm so excited i'm gonna i want to stream oh these guys are
back i want to stream mgs4 but i also have just been itching
to play it myself this is still lit interesting oh yeah we
got the smooth jazz baby smoothy smoothy smooth swish swoop
give me that
Um...
Never listen to Marty.
Guess who got rich?
Buying grandfather collectibles right away.
You kidding?
Be a man.
Keep gambling!
But I don't want to lose!
Listen, most millionaires aren't just born, they come from
risk.
This is literally me!
Dang it!
You are right!
One hour later?
Fuck you, Marty.
Oh, yeah, the elevator's out of order.
Okay, this is our manual hacking.
Oh, shoot.
Screw this.
Yay.
Oh, shoot.
Shit.
No!
Stupid machine.
We can do it again.
Okay, good, good, good.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, we get it.
We did it.
First try.
Easy peasy.
Easy peasy indeedy.
Wait, I thought these were all money, but it's all pineapple
juice.
It's all pineapple juice.
Are you thinking there?
Yeah, we hit the jackpot for real.
Oh, I can steal this.
And this.
Oh, I didn't even notice the cash.
It was 700 bucks.
okay got everything in here now take the juice I mean I
would but I'm just one gal cool I'm glad we found I'm glad I
checked this note then we're able to okay let's see what was
I working on I think I was finishing up over here yes
finishing up over here poor girl
all right the back alleys are clean very good very good
that's a roll of cash in the second logger oh did i miss it
in here
ibu i think you need to get your eyesight checked ibu that's
a cup
left i'm
This?
Let's see.
Um...
Okay.
Dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun.
This guy died so fabulously.
Um...
Uh, you?
You?
There was no need for so many tables anyway.
So true.
And this is all set up.
Very good.
Oh, Wesley!
Thank you so much for the...
Ten gift and thank you!
Oh, we have to see this guy again.
I'm so sorry, everybody.
This guy!
This freaking Gardner guy just writes graffiti everywhere.
Oh.
Oh, disgusting.
Eye boo for eye boo.
Yeah, get your eye boo's checked, everybody.
I'm starting to appreciate the moment when I was standing.
What does that mean?
Oh, he fell over once.
Alright, um...
Come here.
Vincent, is that you?
Who is a Vincent?
A Pulp Fiction reference?
You know I've never seen Pulp Fiction.
Oh.
Oh, come on.
I really don't know my own strength.
If it's a reference, then I don't mind it so much.
But otherwise, it's nasty.
Makes me upset.
Oh, there's bullets here.
Oh, my God.
There's...
This floor looks interesting, but I can't work like that.
Okay.
Take this, too.
We'll just put it somewhere.
technically Vince was coming out of the bathroom yeah you
tell him you tell him you tell him that their reference is
wrong come on yeah it's starting to get tougher and tougher
with how many bodies there are in here come here mister
we're at 7-eleven of bodies I mean the gas station.
Wave King!
Thank you so much for the vibe.
Gifted!
Um, alright.
Get rid of trash 5%.
That's terrifying.
Did I get the...
I don't remember if I got the...
The thing to...
What's the word?
Combine the trash or not.
Can't remember what upgrades I'm getting anymore.
Everything is blending together.
Everything's blending together.
I don't know why some of these things we pick up and some of
these things we don't.
He's not wrong at all.
Each tiny little.
The floor looks interesting, but I can't work like that.
Yes.
Very good.
Okay.
size i think oh yeah i think it was the size of it wasn't it
yeah yeah which is fine we don't have to like take as much
stuff to the garbage which is good or you know what i mean
like obviously we're taking more bags but than if we were to
be able to combine them but it's still a little less look
we're already at 55 percent trash we're so good these tiny
little bullets are so what if you punch it small i can't
help you while i'm lying down what if i what if i just
pulverize the uh the trash into nothingness with my super
strong fist that i don't know how i'm so strong
more stuff here oh my goodness getting this trash out of the
way will be nice though
more bullets Bullets, bullets, bullets, bullets everywhere.
Is there anything here?
No?
I'm starting to appreciate the moment when I was standing.
Um.
No use fixing.
Better to throw it away.
Exactly.
Okay.
Itty bitty pieces.
I would actually believe Minto can throw good punches.
Water builds arm strength for sure.
You think so?
You have so much...
I mean, yeah, with you...
When you go to idol shows, like...
You have to be swinging your pen light around.
Like, it does...
I guess it do kind of build, like, a little bit of a muscle
there because of it.
Because I'm always just...
You have to have the strength to...
To be...
Waving it for so long.
Oh, we got rid of all the trash!
Let's go!
Shady Nantes!
Thank you so much for the gift.
Thank you, thank you.
The floor looks interesting.
Penlight is mightier than the sword, absolutely.
A famous, wise, ghost one's son.
It's a lot of bags.
Holy cow.
Thank you!
Sorry, I have the sound up so high because the game is
actually quite low.
Everyone, they shall now try and support the Minto.
Much love.
Thank you for being the cute guber we know.
Oh, Arlington, thank you!
i didn't say every two weeks then you know how you could
support me monthly by joining membership it's just well i
say it's just two dollars but it's two dollars a month maybe
one of the one of the lower memberships you know you don't
have to do 50 a month you can just do two and that's that's
even way more and then i also will try and do membership
streams and i post little sneak peeks of things as well.
So, you don't have to do so much money.
You'll get even a little bit of benefit if you join the
membership.
Right back, thank you for the gift.
So proliferative, thank you for the gift.
Yeah.
Okay, we don't.
Yes, thank you.
Kruisi, thank you.
Look how I thank you.
try your luck iron all right Wow this place is already
looking so much better so so much better nice this did
someone like throw up here too we got a phone here as
evidence and another guy thank you thank you thank you
someone say membu I can't stand this thing.
Shut up.
An Ibu regardless.
True.
You don't have to join membership to be an Ibu.
Look at how thank you!
Spilled the garlic sauce.
Mmm, garlic sauce.
Oh, yeah.
Nice spin.
That was pretty...
That was pretty sick.
Look, we've already cleaned up so much of this place.
We're already doing so good.
It will be actually probably the cleanest this place has
ever been, unfortunately.
Okay, nice.
Yeah, I want the speed power-up next time so we can, like,
be mopping at crazy, crazy speeds.
The mop is so awesome.
I use it even when I'm not supposed to.
Now I want pizza for dinner.
destroy 30 objects oh my gosh and I have to take out the
trash and then I I messed up.
Maybe the mop isn't so cool maybe I lied maybe the mop could
be nicer because it's very strong and it's like a brute
force like I could have taken that home and had it myself
oh there's still two more but three more bodies we gotta do
right
maybe don't use a mop on the table maybe don't tell me what
to do i'm the maid here are you a maid i don't think so are
you a maid huh also it's telling me to throw the pizza and
stuff around please don't break it won't move like this what
do you mean like this what's wrong with it like
that i need to clear the way first oh my god the pizza on
the wall was making it impossible to clean or to move the
table it's kind of weird
backseat the maid yeah look i'm getting the job done i don't
know about you Huh?
I'm getting the job done.
I thought that nomads would be disbanded after the spawn
incident.
But I guess they're still trying to get their revenge.
Nomads.
Are they like...
Oh.
Are you kidding me?
Every single bag that I thrown has not... Didn't make it in
at all.
Like, I didn't...
I didn't even make a single...
Out of all of these bags.
Didn't make a single throw.
Are we serious right now?
You guys know I used to be on a basketball team.
Zero out of 15.
That's a new record, right?
I'm sitting with an alliance without mind.
I guess they didn't learn their lesson.
Yo, where are you at right now?
Be there in a minute.
That's what you said an hour ago.
Yeah, but this time I'm not lying.
Mr. G there yet?
No, but he's coming.
She'll never be balling.
How did basketball go?
I was benched like 90% of the time.
I only joined because...
Because, uh...
My friend was on the team and she was like, let's play
together!
I was like, okay!
Never played basketball before in my afterlife.
So funny.
Big Jim's head.
I don't think that Big Jim is on the menu anymore.
Maybe I was supposed to clean that.
Ooh, nice.
Glad I had the foresight for it.
Oh, dang it.
That's okay, someone's gotta get the water.
I'm not good at a lot of things.
And basketball is definitely not one of them.
I already know.
I suck at a lot.
On that B-ball team, what?
What?
Were you perchance the ball?
No, because then I would be ballin'.
At least I'd have a chance then.
Oh, oops.
Wow, look at this place!
It's almost spotless.
Besides, like, some of the blood, but don't worry about it.
We'll get it up.
I wonder if I need to do anything with these, uh...
With these, um...
That thing.
Are they all clean now?
I think so.
Yeah.
Something is blocking the way.
No kidding.
There we go.
Oh, come on.
These trays.
We're fine.
They come back, go back, go back.
Yep.
Oh, oops.
It makes such a sad, like, creepy noise.
when you put up something that's dirty.
It's like, no, no.
Okay.
Making pasta with this BGM is kind of peak, I believe it.
There we go.
Very nice.
Yes, yes.
Italiano.
Journal.
Something, something.
There we go.
Okay.
Ooh, furniture, 23.
Okay, these have to go.
Oh, I knew it.
I was going to say, these probably go on here.
Nice.
Wow, you forgot.
Yeah, thanks for the vibe.
Give it to me.
There we go.
There's got to be more.
See, like, we don't have to pick up the pizzas, technically.
So it's just kind of funny, like, what counts?
is garbage you know what i mean oh there's what oh here's
one
oh nice okay there's one evidence that we're missing oh if i
didn't know any better i'd think some tomato sauce that got
stuck on this pan i mean we could just clean it right if
it's any consolation i ran the wrong way doing laps at
basketball practice and the parents took me off the sports
team for life how do you go the wrong what wait like what's
What's...
How is there a right way?
It's my question.
Oh, dang it.
Ow, I knew it.
I knew it.
The way everyone is running.
I know, but you're running laps.
All you have to do is get the laps in, no?
So who cares if you're going out?
Unbelievable.
This glass is intact after all this action.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, we got all the blood.
Yeah!
And we just have to get this garbage.
All right.
and we just have to dispose of this body.
And we're finished.
And I think I got all the secrets.
Yes.
Everyone ran one way.
I ran the other.
I don't know.
Kid brain.
Wow, this one even took less time than some of the others.
I once drove on the wrong side of the road for my driver's
test, so they told me to go back and they said, then.
You failed.
So I get it.
There was what, three secrets?
And we're gonna get so much.
Oh my god!
Nice!
What?
Yeah.
Well, I mean...
So many skill points.
Yes!
Oh my gosh, yes!
yeah end mission
oh yeah let's pet dexter where's my dog what did we get from
that place oh we took a pineapple can dexter's now looking
at my pizza you're such a good boy you don't want to touch
that not gonna eat it oh good boy all right let's see what
we've got going on here mr.
Kowalski perfect child not even a drop of ketchup left so
I've sent you a little present money big gem likes to
appreciate his people did you send me money I also put in a
good word for you in the underworld that's not good expect
customers coming what's the present customers or more
psychos what's the present money oh i hope it's not that ew
a man is driving on the highway when he gets a call from his
wife she says honey be careful some maniac is driving the
wrong side of the highway he says one there's hundreds
is this my present a wife they're nice and perky thank you
very much Thank you very much.
Uh, Big Jim.
They call him Big Jim, but no one's ever dared to call him
Slim Jim.
Let's see.
Uh, let's see what are skills we can get.
I was going to get something.
What was it?
Oh, the cleaning speed!
Yes.
Apply.
Mops get stained 25% slower.
Mops ability to clean difficult stains.
we'll do that one and then apply oh no we can only do one or
the other I feel like the increase all stats even further is
good Elena Elena meet your new mother stores water and an
attachment enabling one-time cleaning of the mop without the
need for a bucket no I think the stats further is better,
no?
Because like
it cleans everything.
Yeah, this is only one time.
I think the stats is everything gets a buff, so I think it's
better.
Yeah, we'll do that.
Alright, cool.
Now we have four left.
Let's do... I haven't used the pressure cleaner very much.
I mean, I haven't really thought of a need for it.
Then we could do the garbage stuff together.
Okay.
water what's this one again improve oh you can pour three
detergents that's right increased quantity of the detergents
which i keep forgetting to use garbage upgrades pretty cool
yeah like the combined let's do that because we had so many
before right oh but now i only have one left that's right
that's okay um
slows down the rate of which tools get stained by 30% that's
pretty good too with our detergent I could do that or this
is plus one mop I haven't really done anything for my sponge
but I feel like it's pretty good we'll do the increased
strength on my sponge okay cool so those will be for next
time
let's go to bed i'm excited to see what our next job is like
we're not gonna do it today though unfortunately garbage
upright is pretty good mountainside villa it's open just
come in this sounds huge a villa sounds like it's gonna be
humongous do you want something to drink
He's having a drink now.
Who else is he shooting?
Mom, what are those noises down there?
Uh-oh.
Oh, no!
Mmm, soup.
Weefy.
Oh, never mind.
I wasn't drinking it.
Who's calling me?
Getting a call before the job is rare, right?
I need your services, man.
an affair with my wife so i just offed him and his entire
family the problem is i didn't really think it through so
you'll need to get rid of the surveillance footage as well
i'll send you the address over email i just need to wash
this blood off me first that doesn't sound good but duty
calls duty calls look at all our duckies wait i feel like
we've gotten more than this Where are they all?
Like, I picked up that one guy.
The one that was, like, Whack.
Oh, look, we're painting even more.
Wow, we're doing a lot of work.
Daughter's room still looks the same.
That's pretty cute.
I saw you pick up a red ducky.
Yeah, weird.
Hmm.
Oh, invoice.
Elena Kovalski.
Follow-up consultation is $1,200?
Physical therapy, yikes.
Specialist consultations, medication, accommodation, balance
due, $28,090.
Golly.
Where's my dog?
Wait, actually, where's my dog?
Dexter?
Where is he?
Backyard?
Maybe?
My free health care heart can't take that price yeah
non-americans don't look hello
neighbor i hope you're not tired of me mr kovalski because
you know what trisha and i are moving in together to an
apartment close to yours oh it's this guy again maybe now
it'll be easier to meet catch up and just chat you should
come visit us right now we are just renting but you see big
jim seems to like me and pays me really well something's
definitely gonna happen to tyler maybe one day me and trish
That would be amazing.
We've already started saving money.
I can't believe it all is going so well.
Okay, Tyler.
Drive straight to King's Crossing Street 6, Crampton's
District.
Erase the surveillance footage.
You'll need five body bags.
Don't forget about that dead asshole.
That dead asshole is in the basement.
Make it look nice and clean and better not F this up.
Remember, you owe us.
Okay, buddy.
I don't care.
I don't care Pedro.
Pedro, rascal.
You are a little rascal, you know that?
Where's my dog?
I'm worried at the moment.
Wait, why do we have like a heater down here too?
That's kind of funny.
Dog?
Tyler's getting the death flags for real.
Maybe he'll come back after the job.
What?
This is where we end it today.
Thank you guys for, sorry for the switch in schedule again,
but thanks for letting me just chill with some, with some,
ah, some nice crime scene cleaner.
I'm really liking this game, so really loving the
environmental storytelling this game has.
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you, thank you, Merlin.
Thank you, thank you.
I hope you guys are enjoying crime scene cleaner.
We'll continue next week, so, hmm.
Yeah.
I hope your throat feels better.
Thank you.
I was coughing a lot today, so I'm glad that I wasn't
coughing so much on stream today.
Thank you so much for the stream and you're good at so many
things.
Streaming, singing, wiggling, mopping, ketchup, throwing
bodies.
Thanks, Argo.
Thank you for the pink.
And thanks for the kind words.
Thank you.
Number one.
It's pretty neat.
Way more in depth than I thought it'd be, right?
It's actually like I'm invested so much now loving this so
far.
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you, Sprank Yeah, cuz like you know with some games
like you know power wash simulator It's kind of one of those
like oh We you can I can kind of like pick it up whenever
Ben thank you It's kind of just like oh, yeah, I'll power
wash Whenever but with this game I feel like I'm really
invested in it and it's fun and Yeah, I'm curious where it's
gonna go with big gym and everything so we will um we will
continue it next week not long from now so yeah let's meet
though everybody thank you so much have a good day have a
good night and i will see you when i see you next happy time
zone bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye
Oh, thank you so much.
Thanks for tuning in, even though your throat wasn't feeling
the greatest.
Yeah, I'm gonna go rest it now and not use it at all for the
rest of the night.
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.
Have a good night.
Bye-bye.